[Musik]
sie gilt als eine der schönsten
Zugstrecken der Welt und erstreckt sich
einmal quer durch die Schweizer Alpen
die Rede ist vom Glacier Express ich
habe mich also auf den Weg nach St
Moritz gemacht um dort in den glass zu
Express zu steigen und ich muss sagen
das hat sich wirklich krass gelohnt
Leute es war unfassbar schön ich wünsche
euch ganz ganz viel Spaß mit dem Video
[Musik]
und damit herzlich willkommen aus St
Moritz Alter Leute was geht ab ich bin
gerade hier in St Moritz ich war noch
nie in der Schweiz gerade aufgestanden
mit Blick aus meinem Hotelzimmer schaut
euch das einfach mal an hier müsste
jetzt jeden Moment die Sonne aufgehen
und ja ich mache mich jetzt gleich auf
den Weg weil wir fahren heute mit dem
Classic Express und ich glaube das wird
schon echt geil und mir super oft in den
Kommentaren von euch empfohlen und ich
dachte mir kommt das passt super in
diese Reise rein und ja geht schön durch
die Schweizer Alpen ich freue mich und
ich würde sagen wir verlieren gar keine
Zeit denn ich möchte gern von hier aus
zu Fuß zum Bahnhof gehen und noch ein
paar Eindrücke von St Moritz zu nehmen
let's go
so Leute in St Moritz wird so langsam
hell man muss ja schon sagen das ist ein
absoluter reichen Ort also hier ist
alles Arsch teuer meine Übernachtung war
jetzt überraschenderweise dann auch
teurer als gedacht aber naja da muss man
durch ich habe übrigens nicht mal
Handschuhe dabei wir haben gerade noch -
16° oh man ich habe übrigens heute im
Glacier Express nicht die exzellent Glas
gebucht das wäre das teuerste gewesen
für über 500 € da hat man halt quasi
einen eigenen Service und sonst was und
bekommt die ganze Zeit essen Pieper hoch
das war leider schon ausgebucht ja also
der Classic Express ist super gut
gebucht es ist echt schwierig da einen
Platz zu bekommen das hat jetzt auch bei
mir gerade noch gut reingepasst weil wir
haben heute Mittwoch und nur Mittwoch
gab es noch drei Plätze in der Förster
also es gibt die Standard-Klasse die
zweite Klasse dann gibt's die erste
Klasse und halt diese exzellen class und
ich habe für das ganze jetzt knapp 250 €
bezahlt ich habe allerdings auch essen
dabei also ich habe mir so einen Menü
zusammengestellt ich bin echt mal
gespannt der Youtuber Dave der hat ein
Video gemacht
in dieser excellen class ich verlinke
euch das war sehr interessant eigentlich
kann man sich ja dann auch danach mal
anschauen wenn es sich schon gesehen
habt und ich kann euch sonst danach auch
sagen ob sich das überhaupt lohnt diese
excellence class oder vielleicht die
First Class auch absolut reicht für die
Hälfte Alter
let's go
[Musik]
ich muss wirklich sagen das ist schon
also St Moritz ist schon wild da oben
die ganzen Hotels und hier ist es auch
so schön ruhig
paar enden wir müssen weiter denn ich
muss mein Zug erwischen so Leute
ich habe sofort geschafft dahin ist auch
schon der Bahnhof ich glaube der Zug
müsste auch schon da sein bevor wir
weitermachen Leute ich bin ein bisschen
heiser aber die zugvideos haben nicht
mal 50% von euch abonniert deswegen
abonniert super gerne den Kanal ich
würde mich so freuen für weiteren
Content yay und jetzt geht's weiter mit
dem Video let's go ich bin am Bahnhof
und da ist er
so gleich geht's los hinter mir ist der
Zug und wir gehen jetzt mal zu meinem
Balkon das hier ist übrigens Glas da
habe ich aber nicht gebucht leider oh
Mann das sieht echt geil aus so und hier
ist jetzt erste Klasse ja sowas habe ich
genau ich muss zu wagen Nummer 24
classic Express okay für mich geht's
übrigens auch nur noch Andermatt also
Leute eingestiegen in den Zug und ich
muss sagen ich war erstmal ein bisschen
verwirrt weil ich gemerkt habe das ist
gar nicht die erste Klasse sondern die
zweite Klasse aber ich sitze auf meinem
Platz zumindest gab es kein zweiten
Wagen 24 eigentlich habe ich schon
Einzelplatz ein bisschen komisch weil
jetzt habe ich so einen Typen gegenüber
von mir sitzen aber gut warum das so war
erklärt uns gleich erschaffen
[Applaus]
wir konnten St Moritz dann aber auf die
Sekunde genau verlassen und der
Schaffner meinte als kleine
Entschuldigung möchte er uns während der
Fahrt Informationen geben wo wir lang
fahren irgendwelche geschichtlichen
background Infos weil er das ganze ja
logischerweise tagtäglich macht und sich
super auskennt und ja der Typ war
wirklich super nett ich habe dann aber
erstmal den Ausblick genossen und ich
muss sagen Leute es war wirklich
unfassbar ich werde auch einfach die
Aufnahmen laufen lassen ich will nicht
zu viel schneiden genieße es einfach und
manchmal ist dann einfach in diesem
Video ein bisschen Musik hinter malt und
ich sag gar nichts einfach weil es so
schön aussah also lehnt euch zurück und
genießt die Fahrt des letzter expresses
[Musik]
eigentlich fährt der Classic Express ja
von St moritz nach Zermatt oder
andersrum man kann aber auch jederzeit
aussteigen insgesamt ist die Strecke 291
Kilometer lang und man überquert dabei
291 Brücken und auch 91 Tunnel wobei mir
so viele Tunnel gar nicht aufgefallen
sind der höchste Punkt ist dabei der
oberalpass auf 2033 Höhenmetern da
durfte ich in der Nähe auch später im
Video mal kurz aussteigen es gibt aber
auch noch ein Bahnhof in der Schweiz auf
3.500 Metern den habe ich auch noch
besucht auf das Video könnt ihr euch auf
jeden Fall auch freuen
[Musik]
ich habe mir dann erstmal die Karte
angeschaut wobei ich auch im vorhinein
schon ein zwei Gänge-Menü gebucht und
bezahlt habe das hat mich 42 Schweizer
Franken gekostet diese 42 Franken waren
aber schon in den 250 Euro die ich euch
am Anfang genannt hatte drin sind
natürlich alles Schweizer Preise die
Schweißes Arsch teuer für mich ging es
dann los mit dem Cappuccino hier für
umgerechnet 6 Franken 50
und wir sind dann so langsam auch schon
aus den Bergen rausgefahren durch Orte
wie cool meine ich hieß das wie man hier
sehen kann da liegt jetzt nicht mehr so
viel Schnee aber war auch super schön
also eine wirklich sehr sehr
abwechslungsreiche Reise mit Schnee auch
mal keinem Schnee Bergen Flüssen Steine
ganz viele hohe Steine
und um 12 Uhr wurde dann pünktlich das
Mittagessen serviert vorneweg gab es für
mich eine
kürbiskernkastaniensuppe das war die
leckerste Suppe meines Lebens wirklich
also die war unfassbar gut
[Musik]
und dann gab es als Hauptspeise
Rinderfiletstreifen mit Spätzle und so
ein bisschen Gemüse auch hier muss ich
sagen super lecker wirklich zehn von
zehn kann man mit einem absoluten Top
Restaurant vergleichen und ja gerade mit
der Aussicht einfach ehrlich
[Musik]
dann wollte ich noch die Panorama Bar
abchecken die habe ich in dem
Reiseführer gefunden nur ja ich muss
sagen das hat sich jetzt nicht so ganz
gelohnt da stand halt ganz viele Koffer
und das war mir jetzt dann irgendwie
auch zu doof dann Getränk zu bestellen
weil die Aussicht hatte ich auch von
meinem Platz einfach genauso gleich
genießen können also die Panoramabahn
und glassexpress macht meine Meinung
nach wirklich keinen Sinn hinter mir war
auf jeden Fall jetzt auf die Panorama
Bar aber
auch ein bisschen besonderer vorgestellt
und dann ging es aber auch schon wieder
in die Berger rein Richtung Andermatt wo
es für mich ja rausgehen und das war
auch noch mal wirklich richtig geil
auf jeden Fall krasse aus
so leute wir machen hier gerade einen
kleinen Zwischenstopp
ja also das ist auf jeden Fall schon
eine zugver die ich nie vergessen werde
richtig geil kann ich echt nur jedem
empfehlen
Andermatt an und da heißt es für mich
leider aussteigen echt schade
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so Leute was geht ab ich bin
mittlerweile angekommen hier in darf ich
sagen wo du wohnst ja ne Olten in Olten
beim Loris und zwar geht's jetzt bei mir
um die Bewertung des Classic expresses
das ist auch schon mal gefahren ne und
wie fande den so ja ich bin wunderschön
ich muss auch sagen das war bis jetzt
auf jeden Fall echt so der heftigste Zug
und die coolste zug-erfahrung die ich
bis jetzt gemacht habe und ich habe
schon einige Züge getestet naja auf
jeden Fall habe ich immer so ein paar
Kategorien die wir jetzt kurz durchgehen
und ich bin mal gespannt wo wir am Ende
landen so wir starten mit Komfort hier
muss ich sagen Sitze waren sehr bequem
ihr habt wahrscheinlich mitbekommen mein
Waggon ich habe ja eigentlich erste
Klasse gebucht der ist irgendwie
ausgefallen technischer Defekt und dann
haben die Waggon der zweiten Klasse da
reingesetzt weil sonst wäre ich halt gar
nicht mitgekommen was ich dann auch okay
fand denn noch was super komfortabel
aber weiß jetzt auch nicht so krass
komfortabel war wie ein anderen Zügen
muss ich hier viel geben weil das waren
halt so sitze wie dieser also jetzt
keine wilden Sitze man muss ja auch
festhalten dass sind ja eher so ein
bisschen ältere Waggons ne Fenster also
es ist ja nur nach außen also dies ist
ja alles um Glas ja aber innen drin die
die Sitze die sind ja nicht unbedingt
die neuesten auch so dass also für mich
sein die schon relativ neu aus aber sie
waren jetzt halt nicht so mega bequem
aber trotzdem was unterm Strich
komfortabel vier von fünf das Essen ganz
klar war super super lecker 55 Sterne
definitiv die Suppe ich glaube das war
die wirklich das war die beste Suppe die
ich in meinem Leben gegessen habe ich
habe noch nicht so viele Suppen gegessen
aber jetzt doch schon einige und die hat
mich umgehauen das war eine Kürbiskern
kastaniensuppe ja die war wirklich wild
also fürs Essen 555 auch gerade dieses
Hauptgericht was ich hatte mit den
Spätzle und den
rinderfiletstücken war sehr sehr wild
nächster
Sterne die Mitarbeiter das gleiche
Express 1A ich muss wirklich sagen super
nett für jeden Spaß zu haben haben sich
echt mega mega gut um uns gekümmert und
ich habe mich sehr sehr wohl gefühlt 55
Sterne da habt ihr echt Glück hier mit
den schafften an diesem super freundlich
das ist mir auch in den anderen Bahnen
aufgefallen da musste man nach
Deutschland kommen machen wir weiter mit
naturerlebnisfaktor auch hier die
geilste Zugfahrt die ich je gemacht habe
die Aussicht Panorama einfach genial ich
kann es jedem von euch nur empfehlen 55
Sterne und zuletzt Preis Leistung ja ich
habe 250 € knappe bezahlt plus dann noch
mal 12 € für mein Cappuccino und Cola
zusammen also günstig ist es was anderes
aber ich fand den Preis trotzdem
ziemlich hoch und was noch dazu kommt
der First Class Waggon ist ausgefallen
deswegen muss ich fairerweise auch da
noch einstellen abziehen da landen wir
dann am Ende bei drei von fünf Stern
macht also somit am Ende 22 von 25
möglichen Stern und ich glaube da
müssten wir mit dem Eurostar auf Platz 1
liegen und um die Frage vom Anfang zu
beantworten ob sich der Classic Express
in der excellence Lounge noch mehr lohnt
oder ob es halt das Geld wert ist wie
gesagt im Winter kostet der 700 Euro
meine Antwort ganz klar nein es sei denn
man ist einfach Multimillionär dann
let's go aber keine Ahnung so für
jemanden wie mich hat das völlig
ausgereicht ich habe mich pudelwohl
gefühlt und ich brauchte gar nicht mehr
Luxus also alles super aber 700 € ist
dann wirklich zu viel das guten Leute
das war der Klasse Express lasst mir
gerne ein Abo da für weitere solcher
Videos und wir sehen uns demnächst
wieder ihr könnt mir super gerne Züge
Busse Flugzeuge was auch immer in die
Kommentare schreiben die ich mal testen
soll und ich freue mich drauf danke fürs
zuschauen haut rein ciao